[Music]
in this talk we want to go
a little high level and
we want to describe how we envision the
future
shiny and what we do to to full fulfill
the future
uh my name is philipp i'm the ceo of
absalom
and together with me we have marek our
cto
so we want to share what epsilon built
to empower everyone to create
spectacular
shiny apps
all right so if you're still with us uh
i think we can guess that uh you love
shiny
just as we do i personally believe that
chinese a unique piece of technology
it empowered thousands of scientists and
data scientists worldwide
to share to first to create and then to
share
their analysis and useful tools easily
through the years we've seen some unique
examples
some crazy ones starting from native
ipad ios applications through
software as a service uh shiny apps
uh ending up with offline
uh shiny applications on and on and on
uh just uh through pandemic
we created free publicly available
dashboards
which were mentioned in the press and on
the given days they
received significant traffic so
i think that it is clear by now that
shiny
is ready uh to be used in different
environments enterprise environment
internal environment external
environment
it is being used by governments ngos
and business but
uh if your app is not
basic if it's not simple your success is
at
risk and there are certain constraints
uh that you that every uh person that
works with chinese to be aware of they
are
technical and operational challenges
waiting for you ahead and
we've seen some great apps
fail
if it's navigated correctly these
challenges can be
resolved risk can be avoided and and we
think that
here we've identified what makes
shiny apps successful
so uh
if you want to make a successful app you
need to make sure that people are going
to
use it and to be happy to use it and
uh right now
people really don't want to use a
slow or not great looking
shiny app or any app people people's
expectations are very high
uh regarding the the friendliness i'm
not saying your application is ugly
i just say some applications are
and the the better it looks the easier
it is to use the higher the chances of
getting
buy-in from the people who are going to
use it
at the end of the day and we've seen
some teams building
apps for many months struggling to get
and then to to have an impact and apps
being bigger and bigger
slower and slower
and up getting harder to maintain
every day of course we also seen teams
which manage to create great apps
it is possible uh but it's not always
uh straightforward and also very often
it is not expertise of this certain
people
to to work in in such a way so
uh
either
teams need to be either aware that they
might lose
speed of development because it's harder
to maintain or they need to gain
expertise in other domains which are not
their main.net domain
on the other hand
our background is in
so amazon was founded by people with
background in applied mathematics
and and software engineering and and we
uh
kind of we are attracted to r we are
attracted to shiny
as software engineers and and we think
that this is
uh something we bring to uh
diverse uh community
of of our world and we want to
embrace uh our background with the we
built through the years
uh many different shiny apps we resolve
many different problems
some of them taking months
[Music]
to to getting resolved and we
think that we can share
what we achieved
mark
we we believe that
our background in software engineering
and and our tools that we've created
can help it can be our way to contribute
to
our community and this way we can
empower scientists researchers data
scientists worldwide
to create spectacular apps themselves
we believe that this way graphs can be
created
they can be created faster and also
together we can
encourage more people to try our and
shiny
and and and kick-start their their
journey
uh this is uh this is one slide that i
shared during my talk at
uh user conference in in toulouse
uh and at that time i
uh kind of embraced
advantages of shiny
when compared to different technologies
and
alternatives but
i i think the solution to
building better shiny applications also
lies
in these other technologies and as much
as we have some advantages
we also need to recognize that certain
other technologies
can teach us how can we do better
so
uh with with our
mission statement being being said
uh and
which is to empower data scientists to
create spectacular shiny apps
i will hand off now to marek to show you
some
work that we've actually put into
a fulfilling on this mission and also to
discuss our progress so far
thank you philippe so i'm very excited
to share with
all of you these new developments that
we will be releasing
uh and if you have any questions please
post them in the questions section and
we'll be happy to answer so
a great ui is something that takes your
shiny up to an entirely level
entirely new level uh and we have heard
great talks today from tom and shannon
on bs leap and
teaming from pedro about custom styling
from
dominic who mentioned lots of shiny
extensions
um so so there are a lot of great
options already
however looking at what is available in
other technologies they have not only
bootstrap and semantic for example
actually there are tons of libraries for
user interfaces and so on and
not all of them are yet easily available
for us
in shai so so we are changing a part of
that today
with two new packages
which are shiny fluent and shiny react
and the main thing i want to talk
about today is shiny fluid
um so shiny fluent lets you use
microsoft's
fluent ui and shiny but what is fluent
ui from microsoft
first of all so fluent is a ui library
from microsoft
that is used a lot in their software
if you use fluent ui in your app it can
basically look like microsoft's excel
or outlook and so on
so this means that your app gets a nice
professional look
which is a great fit particularly if
your users
are in large companies and especially so
if your company is already using office
and for example
power bi a lot so we've seen shiny
compete with power bi
quite a lot and almost always one of the
points in favor of power bi was
a better interface so today we want to
bring this
to shiny uh
right so let let me open uh
another page
right so um everything you see here
is a shiny application it's completely
uh
coming from shiny and uh
this is built using fluent ui this is
actually a part of our documentation so
you can browse all the components that
are available
in shiny fluent um like
various kinds of buttons for example
it's it's very configurable so like you
can you can really
have a lot of room in defining easily
using parameters
and the appearance and the behavior of
those buttons
you have uh you have uh
lots of cool stuff like constant
contextual menu
um uh nice nice looking
list lists uh
i really like uh some of the features
that that fluent provides
for guiding your users through the
application especially
uh for the first time uh like
like the coach mark that can appear and
you know contain some explanation
um uh
of course there are nice nice dialogue
windows and and so on it's like just
all of it looks nice and it's so
powerful and and configurable
and so also shiny fluent has
uh a lot of components for which
er often in shiny we used to
have to pull in other packages like
custom packages
to to have a nice uh some kind of nice
input
uh so so a lot of this is already
available
within fluent uh and via shiny fluent in
china
so there's one problem though here
and it is that
fluent is based on react so to get all
this appearance you need to render
it by a react and that's why we built
shiny react which brings react to shiny
and the story of shiny react starts when
you thought just about how cool it would
be to have a reliable and efficient way
of using all the richness of the react
ecosystem in
our shiny apps just think of it there
are so much
um great stuff there's so much great
stuff available in
react like all the frameworks material
ui blueprint fluent
tons of components for charts
maps and whatnot and also
one thing that is super important is
that
facebook's team has put a lot of effort
into
uh improving its performance uh so
so it's it's really fast so it can make
also our
shiny apps faster
javascript uh the developers have
all of this because they use react so we
should have that too
um yeah so in one sentence shiny react
aims to let you easily use
shiny libraries in uh react libraries in
shiny
and i'd like to thank authors of
a package that was available earlier
which is react r
for especially for some of the ideas
that they have in
their package which helped us and in our
scenario
and our goal it uh it just didn't work
for us
um due to some some of the limitations
and one example here is that react r
seems to be focused more on
uh making and importing
um individual components
uh or just a few components and not
necessarily
entire url libraries
so what's special about shiny react
it's first of all you can port entire ui
libraries
um and it's easy for shiny app
developers like
uh the inputs that you get are pretty
close
as close as possible to the shiny api
that we are used to
and i think that was
quite quite challenging to achieve is to
give the ability to mix and
nest shiny in react and
inside that have shiny again like
outputs from shiny and so on
uh so that we can still use all the
shiny components that we are used to
it also provides documentation for the
components
coming from from the original packages
but inside the our documentation
system which is very useful and
basically it solves a lot of practical
challenges that
you just don't have to think about uh
so so this is what made shiny fluent
possible
and i'm excited to see what other
libraries
can be can be made available this way
but let's go back to shiny fluent so
this is a
most basic app and what's special here
is
just you just use the library so we love
the package
shine fluent and then
you just have to wrap your code in you
know
with react function call and inside you
can use
all the components that are taken from
from fluent you can use all of their
properties and
and so on uh so so basically this code
gives you
these two nice buttons
uh but so that's so that you fully
believe me i'd like to
do a quick live demo
so this is an application that we built
just in a couple of hours using
using fluent ui it's again all shiny
um so
a scenario that we picked that let's say
we
want to analyze uh how our sales
department
performs and which sales reps
uh rep representatives perform best
so you can see here those all those nice
inputs uh that i i think
are very very just pleasant to use
it's always an issue with the speakers
so i i really liked how they solved this
in fluent
um
really nice components like like this
people picker
uh which can show you a lot of details
about
uh about the uh
the people that that you pick
a really nice list view
but what's also interesting is that it
what you can see here
this is a regular leaflet map like
inserted with a leaflet
output but this leaflet output is inside
an entire structure which was put here
not
like like we used to do but by by react
so it's not obvious that this works
believe me uh so so this is really cool
that you can this shows that you can
embed
uh what we already have in shiny inside
the react
and then the same here with with this
plotly
plot so
let's so so this is a truly live demo
let's
try to make a change to this app add
some functionality
let's see how if we succeed so let's say
we
want to filter
this list of deals closed closed by by
the sales reps we want to filter out the
smallest deals like
have some minimum limit for uh
for the amount of the deal
so we can use uh well let's let's
find some component that we want to use
so we can pick slider for example and we
can see that slider is just
we just need to insert the slider and
give it
an input id as usual usually in shiny
so let's let's do that let's go to our
studio
uh so we can go to to where
where the filters are this is our ui
code
right so we have we have the slider uh
there's lots of configuration options so
uh
and you can just type you know type a
question mark slider and then you you'll
get that in the
uh in the documentation window uh all
the options available
uh but let's say we define a step of 100
000 and
we give a label we can configure how to
format that
right so this gives us already an input
that we can use in our server
part so now what we need
to do is just to filter the items uh
filter the items based on the input
value
and that's that should do it
let's refresh the app
right and we have the
we have the slider here
[Music]
so i think it looks really nice it's
it's
just a really beautiful slider
uh if a slide can be beautiful um
i i just really like how
smoothly moves anyway it's it's very
consistent with the entire look
um
right we could add some d-bounce here um
anyway as you can see you can filter
out the deals just the to the biggest
ones
um so
coming back to the presentation so the
good news
is that all of this will be open source
uh
and we will be releasing this in the
just in the coming weeks
uh starting with an early access group
so
uh if you're interested please fill out
the
master class feedback form the link will
be at the end of this presentation
uh and make sure to there's a checkbox
which you can check to
be in the early access group for shiny
fluid so
make sure to do that if you're
interested in that
and you can already today uh open the
app with a demo
at this url uh
all right and uh
so the second area that i want to cover
uh
is developer tools so you may have seen
all gusts great talk about
best practices just a while before
uh and what what she did was uh
she shared a lot of best practices that
that we uh
use in the community uh and she did this
in a non-opinionated way so that no
matter
what technology there were there were
some examples but no matter what
technology choices you make
you can still use these best practices
there are a lot of options
um at the same time at epsilon we are
building
patterns and development workflow tools
uh that realize these best practices
uh in a very opinionated way which is in
our opinion
just just works best in most projects
so today i'd like to share with you that
we will be publishing a
kind of first of its kind uh shiny
application framework
so i think that on runs on top of shiny
and lets you be more efficient
for building production apps
so there are a lot of areas that you can
take care of to make your app work well
in production
you don't necessarily have to take care
of all of them
but but if you do it really
really increases your chances of success
so over the years we've built tools for
all of these areas
and in the coming months we will be
gradually sharing them
as a unified framework
so why does this matter basically all
the
points from the previous slide matter
because ultimately
for apps that work in production uh the
users your users depend on them and
we need to ensure that they're first of
all reliable
and easy to maintain but also for our
projects to be successful we need to do
that
achieve maintainability and reliability
while keeping the
development velocity high which like
keep the velocity that shine is famous
for
uh so just some examples of what you'll
get with the framework
out of the box uh much
domain driven application structure
end-to-end tests
uh like on this example of cypress
uh comprehensive but easy to use
dependencies management like olga
mentioned
um data validation
uh so
what's really new here compared to
existing solutions uh i think there are
three main things first of all it's a
complete uh
framework a complete ecosystem covering
giving you an option for all of all of
the
points uh that you need to think of
then it's uh just
the fact that we bring best practices
from other technologies
uh in areas where where as
a shiny community we can benefit most
by learning from other technologies and
the third
uh you get all these best practices not
as
as as a as knowledge but as
code so you can start your project from
scratch with all the best practices
included and
you can learn watching which parts you
need
like you can learn each part that you
need from the code that is already
in your project and it's already working
and you can learn from that uh
right so back to philippe
yes so
our workflow and shiny fluent and
shiny react are going to be fully open
source
uh we are excited to share our
frameworks and our way of work
uh but we think that sometimes for
frameworks
are just not enough they they don't cut
it
on on their own and and this is why we
want to create another resource for
our community
so so in other communities if you want
to create
your wordpress page if you want to
create your e-commerce store
if you want to create your static
bootstrap website
uh you can browse
i bet thousands if maybe hundreds
uh depending on the use case uh pre-made
quality
templates and layouts you can choose
pick your uh
pick the one you like you can download
or buy
and customize with with a fraction of
work
necessary to build everything from
scratch
and and this is why we
[Music]
we decided to do the same thing for
our shiny community
so mark
so we decided to share some of
our work our shiny apps are
often complemented for
how they look and we are quite proud
about taking care of a great design
we deeply care here about stuff being
both easy to use and beautiful and
useful
so some of the layouts that were crafted
by
our engineers and designers are going to
be
available some of them for free some of
them
to buy on the on the platform that we
are going to share
with with everyone
so uh what did we promise today
first uh shiny fluent and shiny react
are going to be
open source uh you can create great
enterprise grade applications for
especially for enterprise ecosystem with
shiny fluent
and we should expect more uh
react libraries being ported as
our packages available to us
second we will open source
a lot of our internal tools to empower
the whole community
to leverage what we've discovered in
many of our projects
so that the whole community can
move forward much faster at least we
hope so
third we will help kickstart
hopefully more teams and more shiny
developers their own work
with pre-made templates and layouts
all this we do because we want to
empower data scientists and scientists
and researchers
worldwide to create more and better
shiny apps so that together we can have
more impact
and help other people make wiser
decisions for the data
[Music]
you